angoisse cette fois les compteurs
politiques sont remis à zéro une
nouvelle élection doit avoir lieu d'ici
la fin juin depuis aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs le maire et l'air sortant
Thierry Boutard n'est plus le seul
candidat à sa succession son adversaire
se nomme Brice ravier classé à gauche et
loin d'être un inconnu Faustine
après trois semaines de
suspendida pour la prochaine élection
municipale d'Amboise qui doit permettre
de renouveler en intégralité le conseil
après les démissions en cascades de
nombreux élus une liste qui sera opposée
à celle du maire sortant qui a déjà
annoncé depuis le 22 mars dernier qu'il
se présentait à sa propre réélection
c'est vraiment
des femmes et des hommes qui ont envie
d'agir pour moi ce qui ont vu que
Thierry Boutard pendant trois ans a
quand même fait en sorte que la ville
d'Amboise soit totalement inactive
totalement endormie et pour lequel nous
notre objectif il est vraiment de se
dire il faut il est temps d'agir il est
temps d'agir pour angoisse déjà candidat
perdant de seulement 43 voix face à
Thierry Boutard en 2020 Brice ravier est
aujourd'hui rejoint au sein de sa liste
par Sandra Guichard et Christophe Galand
de candidats qui s'était pourtant aussi
présenté à la tête de deux autres listes
concurrentes au dernier élections cette
fois ce qui nous a poussé à nous rallier
c'est d'abord de s'être d'avoir j'ai
commencé à se connaître qu'on en sait
trois années plutôt que de regarder nos
différences peut-être que l'urgence
était de voir nos points communs et
d'aller chercher un chemin ensemble je
pense que si on fait abstraction de nos
différences c'est qu'on se qu'on se
projette résolument pour en boîte je
pense qu'on a des points de convergence
et ces points de convergence faut les
mettre en action pour le territoire pour
les habitants surtout pour l'instant
aucun des 10 démissionnaires de la liste
de Thierry Boutard passer dans
l'opposition n'a rejoint leur union
certains conseillers qui avaient
démissionné au cours des derniers mois
ont même annoncé renoncé à intégrer une
liste jusqu'à la fin de ce mandat c'est
le cas de Marie Arnoux et Rémi le veau
c'est vraiment un choix purement
personnel et professionnel il n'y a
aucune animosité politique avec Brice
ravier aucune dissension
l'idée c'est vraiment de me concentrer
sur autre chose en s'unissant
l'opposition espère augmenter ses
chances d'être élu mais cette liste
pourrait bien ne pas être la seule face
à Thierry Boutard une autre liste est en
cours de formation autour de Dominique
berdon un ancien acteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire à Amboise pour
l'instant une quinzaine de noms sont sur
sa liste il lui en faudrait 35 pour
pouvoir se présenter